CHRIS.
>> Chris: JACQUI, THANK YOU.
AND JOINING US NOW, DR. VIVEK
MURTHY, FORMER SURGEON
GENERAL AND COCHAIR OF THE BIDEN
TRANSITION COVID TASK FORCE.
DOCTOR, THE LATEST NUMBERS ON
THE COVID SURGE ARE DEEPLY
ALARMING.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF
THEM.
MORE THAN 184,000 NEW CASES JUST
ON FRIDAY.
THAT’S UP 76% OVER THE PAST TWO
WEEKS, MORE THAN 68,000 PEOPLE
NOW IN HOSPITALS AND MORE THAN
1400 DEATHS FRIDAY.
QUESTION, WHAT’S GOING ON?
WHAT’S CAUSING THIS REALLY
TROUBLING SEARCH?
>> Dr. Murthy: WELL, CHRIS,
YOU ARE RIGHT THAT WE ARE IN AN
ALARMING PHASE OF THIS PANDEMIC.
BUT THESE ARE STAGGERING NUMBERS
THAT WE NEVER REALLY THOUGHT WE
WOULD SEE IN TERMS OF CASES AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS, NOT TO MENTION
THE OVERALL DEATH TOLL, BUT
WHAT’S HAPPENING IS THAT A
COUPLE THINGS.
ONE IS WE NEVER REALLY GOT OUR
CASELOAD DOWN TO A LEVEL THAT
WAS TRULY MANAGEABLE IN THE
SPRING AND WE DIDN’T ACTUALLY
HAVE THE TESTING AND CONTACT
TRACING TO PREVENT SUBSEQUENT
RISES AND INFECTION BUT WHAT’S
HAPPENING NOW IN PARTICULAR IS
THAT WITH THE WINTER AS PEOPLE
MOVE INDOORS, THIS IS ACTUALLY
THE PERFECT SET UP FOR THE VIRUS
BECAUSE WE KNOW IT LIKES -- IT’S
EASIER TO SPREAD INDOORS AND
OUTDOORS BUT THERE’S ONE LESS
COMPONENT HERE WHICH IS REALLY
IMPORTANT, WHICH IS PANDEMIC
FATIGUE.
PEOPLE ARE TIRED.
WE’VE BEEN AT THIS PANDEMIC NOW
FOR MANY MONTHS AND I GET THAT
AND PART OF THAT FATIGUE MEANS
THAT PEOPLE ARE LETTING OTHERS
INTO THEIR BUBBLE, THEY ARE
GETTING TOGETHER FOR IN PERSON
DINNER PARTIES, FOR GAME NIGHTS
AND PUBLIC HEALTH APARTMENT’S
ARE NOT TRACING MORE AND MORE
CASES BACK TO THESE KINDS OF
GATHERINGS, SO YOU PUT THIS
ALTOGETHER AND YOU SEE THE
EXPLOSIVE SPREAD THAT WE HAVE.
>> Chris: SO, WHAT IS THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION DOING WRONG
AT THIS POINT GIVEN THAT A LOT
OF THIS JUST SEEMS TO BE BAKED
INTO THE CAKE AND WHAT
SPECIFICALLY -- AND I MEAN
SPECIFICALLY -- WITH THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DO BETTER?
>> Dr. Murthy: THERE ARE A FEW
THINGS FOR US TO THINK ABOUT
WHEN ADDRESSING THE CURRENT
SURGE AND ONE THING WHICH
EMPHASIZES WHEN YOU GET TO
NUMBERS THAT ARE THIS BAD I’M OF
THE MOST IMMEDIATE THING THAT WE
CAN DO TO REDUCE THE SPREAD
ACTUALLY LIES IN OUR BEHAVIOR
AND THE CHOICES THAT WE MAKE.
IT TURNS OUT THAT WEARING MASKS,
KEEPING HER DISTANCE FROM
OTHERS, WASHING OUR HANDS, THESE
SEEM ALMOST TOO SIMPLE I’M A BUT
THEY A POWERFUL AND ACTUALLY
REDUCING THE SPREAD, BUT WHAT
VICE PRESIDENT -- WHAT
PRESIDENT-ELECT BIDEN IS -- HAS
TALKED ABOUT IN TERMS OF HIS
PLAN, WHAT HE WANTS TO DO
DIFFERENTLY, WHAT HE WANTS TO
EMPHASIZE FOR DAY ONE, HE REALLY
PLANS TO FOCUS ON EXPANDING OUR
TESTING CAPACITY SO THAT WE CAN
DO BETTER SURVEILLANCE, TESTING,
DIAGNOSTIC TESTING, BUT ALSO
INCREASE OUR CONTACT TRACING FOR
SO WE CAN CONTAIN INFECTION ONCE
WE FIND IT.
HE WANTS TO INCREASE THE
PRODUCTION OF PPE OR PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT SO OUR HEALTH CARE
WORKERS ALL HAVE MASKS AND
GLOVES WHEN THEY NEED IT AND HE
WANTS TO REALLY PUT CLEAR
GUIDANCE TOGETHER,
EVIDENCE-BASED GUIDANCE SO THAT
SCHOOLS AND BUSINESSES, BUT ALSO
FAITH ORGANIZATIONS, SPORTS
LEAGUES, AND FAMILIES, KNOW HOW
TO OPERATE SAFELY.
CHRIS THOUGH, I SHOULD JUST SAY
ONE MORE IMPORTANT THING HERE,
WHICH IS NONE OF THIS IS GOING
TO BE POSSIBLE IF WE DON’T
REBUILD PUBLIC TRUST.
THAT’S REALLY THE MOST IMPORTANT
FOUNDATION HERE.
THE WAY YOU DO THAT IS BY
COMMUNICATING HONESTLY, BY
LEADING WITH SCIENCE AND
SCIENTISTS IN THE FACE OF THIS
PANDEMIC AND ULTIMATELY BY
DELIVERING RESULTS.
>> Chris: IS THE DELAY IN THE
TRANSITION BECAUSE
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS CONTESTING
THE ELECTION -- IS THAT DELAY
HURTING THE ABILITY OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO TAKE OVER ON
JANUARY 20TH IN DEALING WITH THE
COVID PANDEMIC?
>> Dr. Murthy: WELL, IT’S VERY
IMPORTANT, CHRIS, FOR THE
TRANSITION TO BE ABLE TO TALK TO
THE EXISTING AND ADMINISTRATION
AND THE REASON IS THERE ARE
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
CAREER CIVIL SERVANTS AND
POLITICAL APPOINTEES WHO HAVE
BEEN WORKING VERY HARD ON THIS
PANDEMIC FOR MANY MONTHS NOW.
THEY HAVE PLANS THAT ARE IN
PROCESS.
THEY HAVE DATA THAT THE PUBLIC
DOESN’T ALWAYS HAVE ACCESS TO
AND TO BE ABLE TO SEE THAT DATA,
SEE THOSE PLANS, IT’S WHAT’S
GOING TO HELP US PUT TOGETHER
THE BEST POSSIBLE PRODUCT IN THE
END, SO THOSE DIALOGUES ARE
CRITICAL.
YOU WANT TO GET THEM STARTED AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE AND THERE’S A
LOT OF WORK FOR US TO DO NOW
STILL EVEN THOUGH WE DON’T HAVE
ACCESS TO THE DEPARTMENTS, SO WE
ARE GOING TO NEED THAT AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE TO MAKE THIS ALL
WORK WELL.
>> Chris: ONE OF THE BIG
QUESTIONS OF COURSE IS WHETHER
THE COUNTRY IS GOING TO HAVE TO
ENGAGE IN ANOTHER LOCKDOWN.
ONE OF YOUR COLLEAGUES ON THE
COVID TASK FORCE, THIS -- TALK
THIS WEEK ABOUT A POSSIBLE 4-6
WEEK NATIONAL LOCKDOWN AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP RESPONDED TO
THAT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE CAN PAY PEOPLE TO LOSE
THEIR JOBS.
WE CAN PAY SMALL BUSINESSES, WE
CAN TAKE CARE OF CITIES, STATES
AND COUNTY GOVERNMENTS.
>> THIS ADMIN INSTRUCTION WILL
NOT BE GOING TO A LOCKDOWN.
HOPEFULLY THE DASH WHATEVER
HAPPENS IN THE FUTURE, WHO KNOWS
WHICH OF ADMINISTRATION WILL BE,
I GUESS TIME WILL TELL, BUT I
CAN TELL YOU, THIS
ADMINISTRATION WILL NOT GO TO A
LOCKDOWN.
>> Chris: PRESIDENT-ELECT
BIDEN SAYS HE’S NOT THINKING OF
A NATIONAL LOCKDOWN.
ONE OF YOUR COLLEAGUES ON THE
TASK FORCE SAID THIS WEEKEND
YOU’RE THINKING NOT OF AN ON/OFF
SWITCH BUT MORE OF A DIMMER
PERIOD OF HAVING SAID THAT, THE
GOVERNOR OF NEW MEXICO JUST
ISSUED A TWO WEEK STAY AT HOME
MEASURE, THE GOVERNOR OF OREGON
IS TALKING ABOUT A PARTIAL TWO
WEEK LOCKDOWN.
CAN’T YOU HONESTLY SAY IF THINGS
GET BAD ENOUGH, AREN’T WE GOING
TO NEED A NATIONAL LOCKDOWN?
>> Dr. Murthy: WELL, THAT’S A
MEASURE OF LAST RESORT, CHRIS
AND I’M GLAD YOU RAISED TO THIS
BECAUSE THE WAY WE THINK ABOUT
LOCKDOWNS I THINK IS DIFFERENT
NOW THAN IT WAS IN THE SPRING.
IN THE SPRING WHEN WE DIDN’T
KNOW A LOT ABOUT COVID, WE
RESPONDED IN A SENSE WITH AN
ON/OFF SWITCH.
WE JUST SHUT THINGS DOWN BECAUSE
WE DIDN’T KNOW EXACTLY HOW THIS
WAS SPREADING AND WHERE IT WAS
SPREADING.
WE LEARNED A LOT MORE SENSE THAN
THAT TELLS US THAT THE BETTER
WAY TO THINK ABOUT THESE SAFETY
RESTRICTIONS IS MORE A DIAL THAT
WE TURN UP AND DOWN DEPENDING ON
SEVERITY, AND THAT’S REALLY THE
KEY HERE.
THESE -- JUDICIOUSLY AND
PRECISELY.
IF YOU LOOK AT NEW YORK CITY FOR
EXAMPLE THEY ARE APPLYING NOT
BROADER INSTRUCTIONS EVERYWHERE
BUT LOOKING AT SPECIFIC ZIP
CODES TO SEE WHERE THE OUTBREAK
IS SEVERE.
AT WHAT WE NEED, CHRIS, AND THE
REASON THAT YOU SEE SO MUCH
VARIATION IN WHAT STATES ARE
DOING IS THAT WE DON’T HAVE A
NATIONAL ALERT SYSTEM GUIDED BY
THE BEST POSSIBLE EVIDENCE THAT
CAN HELP STATES AND LOCALITIES
DETERMINE WHEN TO DIAL UP AND
DOWN THEIR RESTRICTIONS AND WE
ALSO DON’T HAVE ADEQUATE
RESOURCES FOR THEM TO PUT THESE
RESTRICTIONS IN PLACE, NAMELY
SCHOOLS FOR EXAMPLE, WHICH STILL
DON’T HAVE RESOURCES TO EXPAND
CLASS SIZES, HIRE MORE TEACHERS
AND IMPROVE VENTILATION.
IF WE JUST LOCKDOWN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY WITHOUT TARGETING OUR
EFFORTS, THEN WE ARE GOING TO
EXACERBATE THE PANDEMIC FATIGUE
PEOPLE ARE FEELING.
YOU’RE GOING TO HURT JOBS AND
THE ECONOMY, YOU’RE GOING TO
SHUTDOWN SCHOOLS AND HURT THE
EDUCATION OF OUR CHILDREN AND WE
GOT TO APPROACH THIS WITH THE
POSITION OF A SCALPEL RATHER
THAN THE BLUNT FORCE OF AN AX.
>> Chris: THEN THERE IS THE
ISSUE OF THE VACCINE, WHICH
SEEMS TO BE MAKING REMARKABLE
PROGRESS.
IF PRESIDENT TRUMP ON FRIDAY
ABOUT GETTING IT OUT AS QUICKLY
POSSIBLE, STARTING PERHAPS EVEN
IN DECEMBER, BUT THEN HE TALKED
ABOUT GOVERNOR CUOMO OF
NEW YORK, WHO HAS SAID THAT HE
WANTS TO CHECK ANY VACCINE THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION DELIVERS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Trump: HE DOESN’T
TRUST THE FACT THAT IT’S THIS
WHITE HOUSE, THE SAID
ADMINISTRATION, SO WE WON’T BE
DELIVERING IT FOR NEW YORK UNTIL
WE HAVE AUTHORIZATION TO DO SO.
>> Chris: WHAT DO YOU THINK OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S STATEMENTS
SINGLING OUT NEW YORK FOR A
DELAY IN THE VACCINE AND HOW
DOES THE BIDEN TRANSITION,
ADMINISTRATION, PLAN TO DEAL ONE
WITH GETTING OUT THE VACCINE AND
ALSO DEALING WITH THE ISSUE OF
PEOPLE’S CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SAFETY, THE RELIABILITY OF
ACTUALLY GETTING VACCINATED?
>> Dr. Murthy: WELL, CHRIS,
YOU’RE BRINGING UP ONE OF THE
MOST CHALLENGING PARTS OF THIS
PANDEMIC RESPONSE, WHICH IS HOW
TO DELIVER THAT VACCINE.
YOU KNOW, WE VACCINATED
AMERICANS FOR MANY YEARS IN OUR
COUNTRY, BUT THE CAMPAIGN WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO BUILD TO
VACCINATE ENOUGH PEOPLE TO
CREATE HERD IMMUNITY IN AMERICA
WILL BE THE MOST AMBITIOUS
VACCINATION CAMPAIGN I BELIEVE
THAT OUR COUNTRY’S HISTORY.
IN DOING THAT REQUIRES PEOPLE TO
TRUST THAT THIS VACCINE IS SAFE
AND THAT IT’S EFFECTIVE.
UNFORTUNATELY WE KNOW FROM
RECENT POLLS THAT A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF PEOPLE ARE WORRIED
THAT THE PROCESS OF DEVELOPING
THE VACCINE AND PROVING IT MAY
HAVE BEEN POLITICIZED, SO NOW
THE ONUS IS ON US TO BE AS
TRANSPARENT AS POSSIBLE IN
HELPING THEM UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
SCIENCE DOES SAY, HAVING EXPERTS
REVIEW THE DATA, MAKING THAT
DATA READILY AVAILABLE SO THAT
EVEN PEOPLE OUTSIDE THE
GOVERNMENT CAN REVIEW IT.
THAT’S WHAT WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO DO AND ULTIMATELY THE WAY WE
ALLOCATE THIS VACCINE IS TO BE
DETERMINED BASED ON NEED AND
THAT AND THAT ALONE -- WE CAN’T
AFFORD TO LET POLITICS CREEP
INTO DECISIONS WE MAKE AROUND
THE VACCINE BECAUSE OTHERWISE WE
ARE GOING TO PUT LIVES AT STAKE.
>> Chris: DR. MURTHY,
THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME THIS
WEEKEND AND WE WILL OF COURSE BE
TRACKING THE WORK OF YOUR